the nfl and the nfl players association
will be getting together for the next
time to continue their discussions
toward a new collective bargaining
agreement this is a strange development
from wednesday because the two sides
were due to get together for three days
of cba discussions
the first day wednesday abruptly mid to
late afternoon the two sides issued a
joint statement indicating
that the talks are already over that
they're very productive beneficial to
both sides but they don't have anything
further to talk about they're going to
cancel thursday and friday and get back
together again reportedly on july 29 and
i
i understand that the news is the news
and the joint statement is the joint
statement and we can either take it at
face value or
we can probe a little bit more deeply
and i choose to probe a little bit more
deeply and wonder what in the world
really is going on here
you've got the nfl
wanting to get a deal done
by the start of the regular season more
on that coming up in a moment
and you've got some real issues that you
need to work through if they're ever
going to get a deal done yeah there are
some
incidental issues little things that
they need to talk through but the big
issues and the two big issues in my view
are how the revenue ultimately is going
to be split
and how much money gets taken off the
top for stadium credits before they do
the split because obviously the more
money the nfl siphons off the top to pay
for stadium construction and renovation
the less money is available to split
between the two sides those are the two
issues
and
now i look at it this way if we couch
this as an extension well
it's not really an extension in the
sense that both sides say hey everything
is working well let's just keep doing
what we're doing they're coming to the
bargaining table and they are
focusing on
big questions like whether and to what
extent the current revenue split should
be changed whether to what extent the
current allowances for stadium credits
should be adjusted these are significant
issues and at some point
there's going to be
some acrimony there's going to be some
hard feelings there's going to be some
tough arguments and moments in
the negotiating room and i'm starting to
think
that the two sides are creating a false
impression that everything is well
just because they realize it's not in
anyone's interests
to create the impression that things
aren't going well
that if they can maintain this idea that
it's all very smooth it's all very
simple it's all very normal while they
fight it out privately
then
the football fan doesn't freak out about
the possibility of another lockout now i
don't know that that's sustainable and i
i kind of wonder
and this is just my idea this is just my
thought based upon the circumstances
that they got together on wednesday
and they began for the first time
to talk about real issues and realize
well we got some real issues here
before we spend the next three days
beating the hell out of each other let's
just press pause on this and let's get
back together on july 29 coincidentally
or not when the members of the executive
committee who have jobs with nfl teams
are in training camp and that reduces
the overall potential for friction the
fewer people you have negotiating
the less the chance that one person is
going to get upset by something that
someone the other side may have to say
so i i think that
that
before they got to the point
where the crap hit the fan on wednesday
they recognized
let's call this productive let's call
this beneficial let's call it a day
let's not get together thursday or
friday let's get together on the 29th
day of july and
maybe that's the moment when they'll
bloody each other up a little bit but
act to the rest of us like everything is
still going very well now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports